Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So this is my inaugural talk around the Dhammapada, just taking the verse and just seeing what we can make of it.
So the first one is a very famous one.
I shall chant the Pali first.
Nāhi virena vairāṇi samāntida kudācana ā virena ca samānti e sādhammo sānantano
Now, the usual translation is something like this, hatreds never cease through hatred at any time.
They only cease through love.
This is an eternal law.
This is an absolute law.
It doesn't really matter.
So that's the verse.
And of course, it's one of the most famous of the Dhammapada verses of which there are close on, I think, let me see.
400 or something, aren't there?
There's a lot of them anyway.
Yeah, well over 400.
And most of these, remember, are taken from the Scriptures, and there comes a story with it.
And the stories can be charming, and sometimes are related, but sometimes I find it difficult to relate to the actual verse.
So
Very fortunately, I have this book, The Dhammapada, which I think is limited in edition by Sri Dhammananda, who was a monk, a Sri Lankan monk living in Malaysia.
And he's kindly reduced the stories to something quite manageable.
So I shall read the story and see what you make of it.
So once there lived a householder whose wife was barren.
Being unable to bear a child and afraid that she would be mistreated by her husband and her mother-in-law, she herself selected and arranged for her husband to marry another woman.
But on two occasions, as soon as she knew the second wife was pregnant, the barren wife gave her food mixed with drugs, causing her to have miscarriages.
On her third pregnancy, the fruitful wife
kept it to herself without informing the barren wife.
But when the latter came to know of it, she again caused a miscarriage.
Eventually, the second wife died in childbirth.
The unfortunate woman was filled with hatred and vowed vengeance before she died on this barren wife and her future offspring.
Thus, the feud was started.
Among their later existences, the two were reborn as a hen and a cat, a dog, sorry, a doe and a leopardess.
And finally, as the daughter of a nobleman in sovereignty and an ogres.
One day, the demon was in hot pursuit of the nobleman's daughter and her baby.
When the lady heard that the Buddha was giving a religious discourse at the Jetavana Monastery,
she fled to him and placed her son at his feet for protection.
The demon was thus prevented from entering the monastery, but she was later called in and both the lady and the ogress were admonished by the Buddha.
The Buddha told them about their past feud as rival wives and how they had been harboring hatred towards each other and killing each other's offspring through their various lives.
They were made to see that hatred could only cause more hatred and that it could only cease through friendship, understanding and goodwill.
Both realized their mistakes and on the admonition of the Buddha, made their peace with each other.
Then the Buddha requested the woman to hand over her son to the ogres.
Fearing for the safety of her son, she hesitated.
because of her devotion and confidence in the enlightened one she handed over her son as directed the child was warmly received by the ogress after kissing and caressing the child tenderly like her own very son the ogress handed over the child back to his mother as a result as a result of this episode there was much goodwill on both sides so
Here we have a very ancient story with ogresses.
I think a sort of nasty Shrek.
And I presume that there's a kernel of truth in the story somewhere.
It could be that a distraught husband came to the Buddha and said he had his two wives were, you know, daggers with each other and could he help?
And when they came to see him, he counseled them.
and they stop their fighting.
But these three words, of course, hatred is undermined by friendship, understanding and goodwill.
So if we go now back to the verse itself and just look at the Pali.
So it's nahi verena verani, nahi just means no or not.
Now, host vera,
That's the root word.
It means hatred, revenge, hostile action.
And this is not semantic, this is not pacified.
This is not brought to an end by this wrong reaction of more hatred.
Kudachana at any time, on any occasion, could be another translation.
But it is pacified by avarena.
So the Buddha doesn't use the word for love, metta, or some other word, karuna, whatever.
He simply puts a negative, avarena, which means that the reaction that we have, or excuse me, the response, the response we have to another person's anger or hatred can be varied.
It doesn't have to be just love, as we'll see in a minute.
And this is an eternal truth.
This is an absolute law.
and we'll see that it's an absolute law when we understand the psychology of it so if we just consider ourselves for a moment and just think back when we hated somebody you know when we severely disliked somebody could have been a personality thing it could be something they did all the time when we felt angry now behind that hatred and anger obviously there's hurt so something has hurt us whether that's
right or wrong it doesn't matter in this case it's the fact that we feel hurt and we want to get our own back so we do that through hating finding a way of getting our own back through revenge through spite or we let it all out in a in a sort of fiery emotion of anger and uh and that's how we we release this this hurt right we turn it towards hurting the other
So you can see that.
This process is.
Sorry, that was a glitch on the on the I'll try and cut it out, but if I can't, you'll just have to accept it.
So if we see that, in other words, if we if the other person
reacts with anger, then of course that fuels our anger.
We find ourselves growing even hotter and more cold in our hatred.
But if the other person asks us, you know, what's wrong, and then we have that occasion to tell them why we feel hurt, and they are prepared to adjust or to do something which undermines my hurt, then of course that hatred
and anger begin to die away.
So now when we understand our own psychology, obviously it's easier to understand somebody else.
So here we have somebody who hates us, right?
We can feel the hate.
Or we have somebody who is bursting with anger.
So our reaction, our natural reaction would be to fight back.
Or if we feel we're not going to win, would be to run.
So somehow we have to stop that from firing up within us.
And the best thing is to is, of course, awareness, to be aware of that immediate arising of that negative emotion towards the person and to be able to come to put something in between.
OK, so here we can look at a story from the Buddha.
the dastardly Devadatta had set this elephant on him and the elephant was, you know, making, running towards him with his trunk lifted, presumably, to attack.
And the Buddha stood, see, fearless, right, not reacting, not running away.
If an elephant, you know, went for me, I would definitely be running away.
And he
held out his hand and offered metta to the uh to the elephant the elephant was so affected by this love that it slowed down finally came to a halt and in fact lowered itself before the buddha in some sort of obeisance so uh that might be difficult for us to grasp these days the power of love but of course we use it people use it um you know to train dogs uh to pacify dogs sometimes
You know, when a dog is barking at you and looks angry, as soon as you open up to it and say, oh, you know, quiet down, come on, boy, you know, don't, it'll sort of, you know, begin to quiet down and finally come and sniff you out and be a friend.
So love is a powerful, you know, message to give to somebody that you're not going to, you know, come back at them, that you're not going to react, you're not going to take revenge, et cetera.
So here we are in a situation where somebody is hating us, perhaps, or somebody is angry with us.
So first of all, is to get in touch with that.
Now, in an actual situation where somebody is being hateful or is being angry, to image that hand in front of you, if you can, and then to absorb their negative feelings, as it were.
So it stays on the outside of your heart.
You can feel it, but you're not letting it in.
And the heart itself may be in this dual state of wanting to be angry, wanting to react.
But we have to go over the top of that.
And the best way that I found anyway is to point our attention directly at to what they're saying.
Now, as soon as you do that, as soon as the person who is angry with you realizes that you're not going to react, it's not going to be a big fiery situation, you're not going to pour petrol on it, and that you're actually open up to understanding why they're angry.
Of course, their anger has got nowhere to go.
It needs something to fire it up.
It needs that reaction.
And therefore, the anger begins to settle down.
And the more they begin to see that you want to understand them, then of course it slowly fades away and they begin to explain why they're angry and why they're in a position of hatred towards you.
And at that point, of course, there's some negotiation, there's some ability to settle the problem most times.
So obviously this doesn't always work.
If the person has set their heart against you, well, that's a situation you have to accept and maybe you have to leave, but maybe you have to accept that the friendship is over or whatever that relationship had been.
That's an extreme case.
Most times, we can come to some understanding and more often than not, the friendship is healed.
So we have a wonderful example there of the Buddha overcoming this terrible elephant from Devadatta.
So that attitude of seeing when somebody is angry or hateful, of actually understanding that they're coming from a position of hurt, there's your compassion.
It's not love, it's compassion, it's an empathy.
because we've been hurt we know what it's like and then the reaction or she was sorry the response the response is one of of love the one of you know opening up to the person and allowing them to express themselves so uh that's the the teaching of this particular verse um and uh it's something that
These verses, if you take them on and you learn them off by heart, they're just like a mantra within us every so often.
It's actually changing our attitude or deepening our attitude of how we relate to situations which are difficult for us.
So that's the verse, hatred.
or anger or anything violent can never can never be pacified by that reaction of hatred and anger at any time it's through compassion through love that we can bring that to an end and this is an eternal law is an absolute law right because we can see the truth of it within our own psychology so
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance and I have not caused even greater confusion and that by your devotion to the practice, you may be fully liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.